[Music]
hello everyone
so in the previous part of the lecture
we had uh
started our chapter on kinematics and we
had started our discussion
on the section of displacement
deformation and displacement
uh we had uh
we had discussed a few things regarding
the initial notions of deformation and
in this part of the lecture we would
like to go forward first of all
with the definition of the displacement
okay
we define the displacement vector
depicted by the symbol u small u
so this is defined as
ah please note that this symbol that i
have just
used the colon in front of the equal to
sign
this is the symbolic representation of
the definition
and we define it by saying that
this is the difference between the
final position vector
which is a function of the initial
position vector
as well as time t and the
initial position vector
so now in component form this will be
given by
uh the three components u1 u2
and u3 but before we write that down uh
from now on what we are going to do is
uh
this dependence on time t uh this
explicit dependence on time t will be
dropped
uh and will understand that even though
it is not written
uh it will be implicitly understood
so
the dependence on t
will be implicitly understood from now
on
so what we are going to write this as
u vector is equal to the final position
vector being a function
of the initial position vector by number
the time t
and the initial position vector x
in component form this basically
means that x1 being a function
the small x1 being a function of capital
x1 x2 and x3
minus x1 u2
like this
and you see like this
it is very important to understand that
uh
even though we have written this u1 u2
and u3
uh alone but really they are
actually themselves functions of
x1 x2 and x3 the reason is very simple
that you see this u1 here
is given in terms of the small x1 and
that is a function
that in turn is a function of x1 x2 and
x3 it means that
u1 itself is a function of x1 x2 and x3
similarly for u2 and similarly for u3
so what we can say
is that q is actually
a function of x
and that is given by
this
okay and we all understand that uh
with reference to our previous diagrams
this u vector this displacement vector
is the
uh the is actually the displacement
vector of the position of the
point p now all this is good
but in order to actually quantify the
displacement
what will required is uh is to compare
the positions
of two neighboring points p and q so all
this while we have been
uh have been dealing with uh
perhaps it will be clearer uh if i i
just quickly draw the diagram that i had
drawn
previously so if we had uh
if we can consider this
three-dimensional body
what we had done earlier was to consider
this point p
which had the position vector x and this
was in the undeformed state
and as it deforms and goes to the
current state
material point p
it goes and becomes p dash and
its position vector is given by the
small x and
we have what we have basically written
here
is that the displacement vector of the q
this is of this point p
all right now as i was
saying in order to actually quantify the
deformation in a proper fashion
what we need to do is consider another
point which is just beside
t may be depicted by the point q and
then to consider
the relative uh displacement between the
t and the q so that is what we are going
to do next
okay so
quantification of deformation
we again consider our three-dimensional
body
with the point p here but
we also consider another point q
which is a neighbor of the point p and
depict
its position vector like this
x plus d x vector
now this is in the undeformed state as
always
and this goes
and becomes in the deformed state
t dash depicted as before by
our small x and the q becomes
q dash represented by small
x plus e small
x this is our current state
to properly go ahead with the
quantification of deformation
what we are going to do is we are going
to consider
the displacement vector not of the
position of the point p
rather of the point q so that will be
given by
u vector not of
not a function of x because we are not
going to consider the displacement
vector of the point p we are going to
consider the displacement vector
of the point q so that is given by
x plus dx
and that by definition should be equal
to
the final position vector
given by x plus dx
minus the initial position vector
capital x plus dx
however we know from our previous
discussions
that
the displacement vector for the point p
as depicted by u being a function of x
that is nothing but small x minus
capital x now you note that in this
previous equation
this small x minus capital x is very
much present
because x is here and capital x is here
so we may write from here
that q vector
or the point q
is this displacement vector
for the point p plus
the rest of it just as before
okay so
from there we can quickly write down
this statement that d small
x vector is equal to d capital x vector
plus
the displacement vector for the point q
minus the displacement vector for the
point
p now as far as
the quantification of deformation is
concerned
this is the statement that we wanted to
come to
however this is not in a very convenient
form what you would like to do
is to carry out some mathematical
manipulations
over this difference between the two
displacement vectors
and simplify this expression to a more
convenient
and more physically interpretable form
so
that will be done in the next part of
the lecture thank you